so how do we do this without spoil I I
think what we'll do is I'm like I turned
to my wife afterwards I'm like I don't
know how we're gonna film this review
because like God I feel like 75% of it
people with some outcomes okay so so
this will be spoiler free for about 5-10
minutes and then we'll just go into
spoilers pretty pointless to make uh
spoiler video cuz you know a lot of its
gonna be spoilers so but this will be
spoiler for you we'll let you know when
we're gonna go into boilers so so for
now we just gonna give our thoughts on
the movie without giving away anything I
go first
are we gonna have an actual fight here
now I know no I I think it did I yeah
well it was I will say this I gotta let
it sit this is what a few marry you
gotta let it sit a bit
it is very old-school Spielberg II where
it's all about the as Tim Curry would
put it and tissa wait for it anyway it's
building up the shark it's very much
like jaws where it's just like you are
waiting for that shark now here's the
thing you're really really waiting a
shark came unlike Jaws fake it to me it
was like worth the wait I just thought
the payoff pretty amazing yeah
Fanta okay so you know how this is kind
of like a reverse Return of the King
you know how return the King has a lot
of like action and big visuals and
emotion and all you character all this
stuff and then the ending it's like well
yeah that's emotional it's good but yeah
kind of drags on it's totally reversed
the first half of this is all the ending
is all the among all the emotional stuff
and
and a lot of retread yeah a lot of
retread you know but but you kinda see
it's like okay that's it's kind of
needed and then you get holy
that's really cool third act that
in my opinion is just flawless I mean
the third act I think is just like from
one point out I'm like this is a perfect
movie like nothing wrong at all but this
movie's three hours y'all have three
hours say this I didn't feel that three
hours in the second half I did feel it
in the first and I will say this part of
the problem and this is where it's tough
because I'm like I feel like it's
necessary but I know you're gonna say
part of the problem is it feels like a
funeral like it's oppressive how the
first half of this movies is all about
guilt grief sadness inability of the
move on like so I'm like but it's it's
tough because in in the in the last
third there's elements of it that then
feel like a funeral to but it's like
it's tight and it and it's it's just the
perfect amount but then I also think I
might so but that could be because they
did take this time not just the time
before that last third between two
frigging movies to do a lot of this and
something a lot of the stuff they're
doing with some of the characters I'm
saying to myself
tee hee ha ha I don't want to see that
happen to some of these characters but
but then there's also like oh this like
a lot of their contracts are up and
stuff like that so this might kind of be
like the finale for them you know like
that this might be it aside from a cameo
or like a prequel film or something like
that so that's something else to kind of
keep in mind but the other thing that my
jokes Return of the King like I know
people complain about those endings but
I think one person at one point told me
that I thought was a very good point
yeah but they they earned that with the
sheer effort was the time it took and I
feel like at 21 movies I'm like you know
and I think they earned this if they
want to you know I'm watching this movie
saying they could have cut a good I
would read this creepy like this is a
great script rip out 40 pages I mean
but then when you see what's building up
to and you see like the other 22 movies
and everything I am kind of like yeah
that's what I carry I think we need to
just straight up say it too part of the
problem is we've got characters that are
supporting dump with each other that are
missing 50% of their member and like
that I'll tell you the Guardians is
where I felt at the most
I love Rocket Raccoon man him on his own
I'm just like this just feels so wrong
like it doesn't work and it doesn't work
and that's fine because it shouldn't
work you should be like god I want the
others and like they pair him up kind of
with Thor and like they try and it is
funny but at the same time it's like no
you clearly need all of them a good
third of the humor in this
I really felt was awkward now I still
think two-thirds work I laugh but
there's a good third where I'm like man
this is just lingering and like just
kind of kick can we move this along and
maybe that's because part of it is the
momentum that there's not as may last
but they're usually good at balancing
that but that's not a huge problem
honestly but that's kind of a new pickup
city to be a folk to the fact that again
we're missing butte like i know you're
probably right that first half felt off
and i'm wondering it was that just
intentional like yeah yeah we want you
to feel comfortable we want you to feel
that this is wrong you I feel like
something missing because something
easiest thing you know like so it's one
of those things where it's like on the
one hand that's Oh Kleber on the other
hand man that's a lot of movie to sit
through with that and that was gonna get
to before is that one of the big things
about is that I found what when I first
saw Back to the Future 2 I didn't like
it and I saw no where's later is because
I'm yeah we thinking this I saw it years
later I still didn't like it but I found
out there's a ton of people that love
that film for me the reason I didn't
like is cuz there's a little too much
reach shredding in the future as us as
it's clever but you're still technically
watching this if you're watching the
same movie
it may be different
keeping away too much even though you
probably put some bass together even
before it's talking about it uh there's
similar ideas going on and that's kind
of the action it's a lot of retreading
and I had to drop it go to a Marvel
movie for the night I go to Captain
Marvel for that to see all the over
yes she's back for like two minutes
mercifully like she had like ten lines
and even then they were awkward so yeah
I don't or credit they shot this before
so that's the difference of a good point
how much did they mess up that movie
that you know because this has kind of
happened before where they shoot these
things out of order like well you look
at black with like a black panther in
infinity war like it's not that there
was a ton of them but because that movie
set them up so well I felt like okay I
know these people I know who they are I
know man now with cap tomorrow I'm like
yep same bland like still don't know
jack squat well what's her thing again
she can fly in space that's like you my
wife my wife liked her better in this
she's like yeah I thought she was a
little better in this one i but I mean
my wife didn't like Captain Marvel the
movie so yeah you might be right maybe
just cuz she can't linger around so you
can't focus on how bland she is which
but even that like I said this from the
trailer - I mean is that I get this is
something where it's just kind of a
casting thing I don't necessarily blame
her but it's kind of like who's the
who's the girl and I really do say girl
cuz she looks like a kid from Batman
Begins she was supposed to be like she
was the girlfriend in Batman Begins
Katie Holmes
she has Katie Holmes central working
yeah you're treating as a yes she's
supposed to be tough and yeah sir can if
she has a voice like
and it's like some people can do that
and pull it off she doesn't have the
acting chops to make that voice really
work for her and be tough because where
she comes up it's there are no forces
down there he is unarmed I'm just like
that doesn't sound right sing the giant
flamin woman coming on it just like I
didn't see anything it like it doesn't
sound right it's in my problem
I ice cuz I've seen actors work with it
before they work with you know you -
voiceover he has a normal voice I think
she's fantastic
ya know exactly how if she doesn't let
the engine chance to really it work with
them I just the movie the original movie
didn't give her any personalities so now
that we're down a personality from her
intro movie like you can't unlike some
of these other characters that may show
up in cameos it's like we've got nothing
to go on so she's still just that bland
kind of blank slate so yeah but I hope
they figure out the sequel what to do it
goes I'm like yeah yeah I mean that's
the thing she's like two minutes so yeah
so the big ten minutes I think total of
screen time out of three hours man you
think you think even yeah about 10
minutes really man
so but yeah like honestly the acting was
I thought really said like Hulk had some
great moments right yeah I think the big
the best thing for me
well Robert Downey and Chris Evans are
always good Black Widow had some
fantastic scenes in this movie and I'm a
big black widow fan so I'm just like yes
finally like her trying to like put
back together like kind of keep like you
know and that's that scene where she's
being informed like couple things is
going on and you could just tell she's
just like just crushed by this news and
like I I thought she had some amazing
scenes in this film and I thought she
was great
everybody was good yeah nobody was bad I
feel like some of the choice keep in
mind and I think most people know
this but keep in mind going in some of
the choices with some of these
characters bear with it because they
either go somewhere or it's like hey
this like I don't know everybody's
contract you know and stuff I mean there
is some stuff where people like with
those persons contract if this person go
down like with some of them this might
be a with some of them there might be
another one or but but but they're
building up like whatever the next part
is starting I think the other thing is
the next one they call it phase as ever
they go yeah like they're building up
okay this is done and that's not like oh
they all die that's not it you know but
yeah but yeah because that would be
great that'd be a great idea but no but
they're definitely building up this is
kind of the end of this phase so it's
which again I kinda have mixed thoughts
about but it's like I don't know but by
the end I'm like this is good this is a
good movie two-thirds in I was like I
don't know I don't know it see here's
the thing too much like when I got to
the halfway point I was just like I my
gut was telling me I'm like this is a
Spielberg trick watch that's gonna be a
giant pan I'm like cuz I thought that
you live I'm like there has to be if not
the audience is gonna riot I just
watched a funeral for three does that
gives you an idea of the kind of movie
where it's like simple a food wasn't
there people would know I don't know I
think I think it works cuz yeah
sometimes it's about the weight that an
anxious minute and I was as we were
getting into the halfway point as we
were getting into the quote-unquote
endgame part of this in that third act I
was getting like really anxious you know
like butterflies in your stomach like
yeah something's comin like this is
gonna be great and when it happened holy
the one other thing just this is really
important going in cuz this again this
is kind of like my OCD whatever if they
get big shock we talked about back to
the future too and stuff like that
there's gonna be talk about timelines
and stuff like that um none of it
matches up at all and they try to act
like yeah no no we thought ahead
we we're not gonna do with the other
movies they even reference other movies
that do this they totally do it it makes
no sense just do not pay it it's comic
books silliness yeah when they play it
out there yes no wonder like no no we
wear a counting frame we're not doing
like these movies yes you are you just
totally are it's it's every one of those
things where you can just replace any of
the gobbledygook about the timelines and
stuff with reasons why yeah no kiss at
first I'm thinking like oh we can't
doing the twelve Monkeys things like how
they did there and I got kind of excited
no no but I thought that's that's what
they were building up they were gonna do
and then they 100% don't so that threw
me for a loop but then again I was
distracted by all the cool stuff in the
last third where I was like okay I don't
care enough having read the comic eons
ago like 1993 from what I remember this
is a way different beast like I was
thinking that they were gonna pull it
out more like the comic in an end game
know they pretty much the first one I'm
so so then maybe it'll come around to
like the Infinity Gauntlet
you know series in in the second one and
yeah after about 10 minutes and I'm like
oh you were really gonna do your own
thing okay and as it kept going I'm like
oh you are really gonna do your own
thing okay you know it's weird because
on the one hand I'm Jenny
okay just cuz there's a lot of stuff in
Infinity Gauntlet that I'm not sure
would have flown like would have worked
and infinity now infinity war which I
think that was the copper sequel yeah
the comic that one was so needlessly
complex I couldn't even see though
that's the weird thing I feel like the
middle part of this movie became kind of
like infinity war where it becomes very
complicated just follows enough and then
I'll guess it at one point I'm like okay
well now I know none of this makes sense
because you've like backtrack five times
on what you said finiti gauntlet was a
little more straightforward but it
yeah don't if you're like a fan of the
comic and a purist just go in knowing
that already like it's yeah by the end
of it you're gonna be like oh yeah that
really has nothing like it's it's the
same characters for the most part except
ones they've omitted but apart from that
it's like I'm like wow okay you're
definitely different but and yet the
funny thing is if if you have like if
you turn your brain on though you can
figure out what's gonna happen it's not
yeah it's not really it's where you have
to turn it out but turn it off at the
same time that's gonna weird there is
one big twist I think in the middle that
I didn't see coming I was like wow but
everything else I'm just like yeah
that's kind of what I I mean they did it
differently than in the comic but I'm
like that's exactly what I thought was
gonna happen yeah the other the one
thing one last thing I'll say before we
go into spoilers is that this movie
honestly in a lot of ways does what I
kind of want a movie like this to do
where it's the trailers especially
building up this is the kind of movie
you're gonna get and you really don't
until the last third and the first two
thirds are something kind of different
they let you know early that they're
going to do something very different and
I mean to a point where it's like even
that they the biggest surprise pride for
a lot of people is just gonna be a
caption that shows a passage of time and
they do it slowly yeah yeah we're doing
this and it's one of those things where
I'm kind of like cool when I saw it like
they're really gonna do something
different then I'm kind of like oh like
that's what a lot of this movies kind of
do okay and then when you realize you
have to kind of sit with it even though
you know it's gonna mostly be done well
it's still like man we got three hours
of this I don't see that much like this
is more it's this movie to me in some
ways felt like that and that's Snyder DC
but like that kind of nolan DC or some
of the other ones where it's just like
yeah let's let's take a moment and do a
little character study here like and I
kind of enjoyed that because I don't I
don't see them when like Marvel's very
jokey and it's
like you know yeah so I felt this was
kind of a nice departure I kind of
sometimes felt like I was watching a DC
movie like oh good so did I yeah I felt
sometimes like I was in Wonder Woman or
something or even some parts of Shazam
where it's just like hey let's just give
you some characters and let you breathe
with them for a while but it's like skip
the action it does take it because I
usually love those scenes too and again
looking back so when you see what it
builds up to and that's kind of the end
of this phase it is like yeah if you're
to ask me what to cut I'm like well
that'd be very tricky wouldn't it cuz
that leads to this at the end of this
list this and at this might be this
character wrapping up here then all
these things so it's one that I thanks
for it like it's it's tough it's it's
complicated yeah it's I think the only
parts for me was the dead center of the
movie the middle part where it gets kind
of back to the future - ish like yeah
and again it goes on a while it's not
but it's not bad it's not if I'm
thinking at the part where I'm just like
yeah I'm a little more disinterested now
and that's the thing there was action
there which is kind of interesting what
you need it because there's not much
yeah but I actually preferred probably
the scenes without the action yeah until
the third act the third act is totally
awesome yeah so it's but but you see
what we're talking about where it's like
ya know it it builds up it gets there
it's a payoff but it's it's a long
build-up so it's a weird mix because it
both does exactly what you think it's
gonna do if you think of the big picture
like I know what needs to happen and you
know through some lights in there that I
don't really see that coming already it
doesn't know it's kind of surprising and
I'll say will probably throw some people
off well that's something that is like
oh my god that's something I didn't
quite get to that point but because I
never got to that in a Marvel movie yeah
I think maybe guardians twos the closest
and even then I'm like I still wasn't
quite eerie and I was like that's legit
sad uh and here it's like yeah like it's
you
it is at the sad moments the moments
where they're really trying to make you
sad and stuff it really is like think
about all that has built up to this not
just you know whatever the two hours
plus before it before it I'm like okay
like you say it goes yeah and so the
emotion feels very genuine yeah it
definitely got me in a couple moments
definitely got my place but yeah what I
think you can figure out from that if
this is a film
hopefully this is a don't see what are
we talking about yeah no so but but
there you go biz spoiler-free okay so
here I'm out spoilers okay okay so we
still get cancer marvel hey I'm assuming
it's like a prequel or something but
it's like that noise like the way
she went to but it's okay it's like Oh
fringed her I'm J I'm sorry that
that legit piss that's the only thing
that threw herself at the yeah she
okay yeah cool cool how does a fella
Frigidaire cuz she so it was fridge
suicide yeah I'm waiting
how's she gonna come back look about
window gomorrah's gotta come back and
she no they found a sneaky cuz I said
was coming down I was talking to Walter
about this we did a podcast and I said
that bringing Gamora back they found a
sneaky way around yeah there what do you
want to find it are three he's gonna
just shackles beforehand that could be
very interesting what did they play a
low they wasn't here to with the the
blue-balled woman you know what what did
the other meet you have nebula what did
I evolve it does to me
got their characters so that could
actually be kind of interesting so but
yeah with black I'm like oh man that
pissed me off what uh a black widow fan
I'm just like what a dumb way to go to
Amy you know what it was killing me too
because I liked them even though it kind
of was like old weird where it's just
like I'm a hardened serial killer now
hey join up with me again okay and then
they're all buddy-buddy again but I'm
like whatever so he kind of relapsed I
guess yeah it and I love love that scene
where they pretty much tell her yeah
like he's just gone nuts and she's just
like so upset by this and yeah she like
Scarlett Johansson and a number of great
scenes in this movie and I loved I
wanted kind of Marvin of her trying to
keep the together with the Avengers
and like carrying on the torch and I
love that she kind of became this sort
of de facto leader like as everybody
else so yeah I'm like I thought this is
cool this is kind of building for
something and then Jesus like jumps off
but like I liked her and Hawkeye
together again and it was really cool to
see them interacting and I'm just like
really the only thing I did like was
them fighting over it yeah it's gonna go
but I as they were fighting I'm just in
the middle of it I'm like Jesus Christ
no because Hawkeye has a family
therefore he can sacrifice she's gonna
do it because she has no connections I'm
like you're really gonna kill
Black Widow but then I felt well they'll
bring her back somehow I'll get I have
to bring this up because I was waiting
for it hold on let me just
militia fish I was waiting for cuz at
that funeral at the end for Tony Stark
III thought laz they were going down
that long for her to pop up her with
Gamora you know okay nope okay to give
you an idea how dark I thought this was
gonna go because everyone's like this is
boy this is amazing I'm like well they
gotta they gotta really you know drop
some balls here and stuff I thought
because everyone you know half the
people are gone custom five years later
as you know if you're watching this uh
Tony Stark has a family and
talking about time travel I
thought it was gonna be a choice that he
was gonna give up his life and he was
gonna have to sacrifice the existence of
his family like that kid was not gonna
exist that's where I thought oh my god
what they're gonna do it that this is
gonna be like so freakin intense in my
plane it's like oh no no no we're just
not doing the time line thing at all no
fan OHS like when he how how you can't
mess up the past she can't change I feel
well past that oh it's just came into
the future so he can't do all this stuff
and he just disappears so now none of
this could happen but again the time
light stuff doesn't that dark no but
that's when it was like no no like we're
gonna when they said we're gonna follow
this timeline thing we're gonna really
follow it it's like oh no it's just
total you know so the timeline
stuff dilligent pissed me off because
they're so explaining no we're not gonna
do this and they so doing that that
annoyed me and they cut um that goes got
around it I um I'm like the comment like
if I remember the comic right nebula
like I think is the one who steals the
gauntlet from Thanos which they were
kind of doing but then so the weird
thing is like Thanos in the comic if I
remember then tries helps them stop
nebula but in this one he just gets like
snap out of existence I'm like okay well
no even slight redemption for this guy
like I guess that's it yeah I mean big
departures there I liked the kind of
concept of nebula being kind of like
crazed and because he's been tortured
all these years in this and that so what
she was before there's a lot of that for
me was kind of a lateral move I don't
know yeah I called it cabba it was Tom
Walter we both agree that we felt
Captain America and Iron Man Iron Man
were gone well I liked it the minute he
saw his girlfriend in the past I just
assumed him and Stark we're gonna
somehow stay in the past and then when
they went for it I'm like okay I'm like
but he he's gonna go know Captain
America was still alive I'm like huh I'm
like what do they do and then that
ending with him passing I'm like okay
got it like yeah which no it melts
nicely done
no I thought that was really nicely done
I thought Tony's death was nicely done
even even with Tom Hollands weird
spider-man is too Iron Man what Marcy is
to peppermint patty there's this weird
like yes sir
third thing but yeah it was really sad
when he's like sir we did it sir we
wanted and and I loved because it was
the complete reversal of what happened
in the previous movie and I love role
reversals and films you know what I
thought that and I and I I got all
misty-eyed with like Pepper Potts came
in it's like it's okay you can rest she
looked awesome in that she got
to like get some screens that's like the
coolest scene in Iron Man 3 when she had
to stand up for a second I'm like who's
that like where he's like helping out
the kid or the kid helps him rebuild the
Iron Man suit and Pepper Potts in the
suit we're like the only two great
things yeah yeah Robert Downey he's
always Robert Downey's great and yeah I
love what they did with Captain America
at they an eye I heart Peggy Carter so
the fact that they brought her back and
the fact that he gets to go back in time
with her I'm just like yeah I'm like
that's yeah thatthat salad Jill my wife
and I love him isn't my wife and I were
watching agent Carter when that was
running when the cancer we were like
super sad so I'm like yes finally get
Haley Atwell back in there you know and
there's again there's scenes like worry
Tony Stark is talking to his dad and
stuff like that and it's the exact
dialogue you would think they would have
together so again in that scene I'm like
and whatever but then when you're like
well but he's gotta be wrapping up this
is gonna be here it's like he sees his
dad for some reason was one of the few
back in time where I'm just like really
hitting the nail on the head guys I get
a little it was a little too kind of
hokey screenwriting for me but it I
thought over all those cute it was nice
to see it work yeah um but Valkyrie I
want Valkyrie when I said Valkyrie on
that like the horse I'm like yes okay
like stuff like what they do with Thor
and Hulk specifically like you see
hongki's this half Bruce Banner half
Hulk now edits very
funny Oh motion kept everything is so
funny by the BeerBelly yeah and Chris
answer has the BeerBelly uh you know he
gets all pudgy and stuff like that t he
ha ha and then I'm like well now wait
for you to change bag and it's like hens
worth I faked us when he gets the hand
he gets the hammer you die and then we
let's go we that like and I'm like yeah
okay whatever comic magic vitally like
Bruce Banner just stays that Hulk the
whole time with that okay if this is it
if he ain't coming back okay fair enough
he's made peace nice wasn't there a
pedal tone uh you know it's like yo
you're building up you're buildin up to
the Hulk he's gonna be even bigger and
crazier cuz he's been keepin it better
and it's like but now it's just cannabis
weird half and half so yeah I like a lot
of it like it first the BeerBelly forced
authority like Widow or like my
favorites out of the Avengers however
she goes back and meets his mother like
it's that's the weird thing so parts of
the middle section of the movie I'm
kinda like yeah this feels like repeat
but parts of it I did actually like like
it's it's it's weird cause like when
he's talking to her it's like half of
that I'm like okay I guess this is kind
of sweet seeing his mom again she kind
of knows although what she couldn't
predict her death how that work and she
knows he's from the future again comics
I guess uh but like half of it I'm just
like I'm getting so annoyed with you
but you are just so Agravaine it seem
like I don't know it's almost like they
let him improvise and like in the Thor
movies that works but here it's like a
lot of those scenes are like at the end
with the guardians I guess he's going
with the guardians now which is let's
see where it goes uh but like where he's
just it's just him and star-lord just
really long really drawn-out really
awkwardly just talking about like who's
gonna be the leader I'm like okay cause
I got it wrap up cry I like that fit oh
I just thought just went on forever I
thought a lot of his scenes went on
forever and
usually my favorite but but there are
some legit Lansing's to tell you you had
a great joke when mo wedding yeah he's
there like looking over the beach he's
got the shades and he still looks like
the dude I just I just want him to hold
up this like Folgers coffee can that
just says Tony Stark on it
Tony Tony who loved iron to do with
Ultron
yeah big like a Big Lebowski joke in
there I think so oh I don't know I like
store it was funny just seeing Natalie
Portman again briefly because like I
think I think she's the only other one
I'm just like when I think of bland yeah
yeah I'm just like oh yeah she was in a
movie two movies apparently and yeah I'm
trying to there's one scene okay so this
is definitely like a power scene where
it's like aspire was a Spider Man he's
got the gauntlet or sorry the Infinity
stones yeah Captain Marvel comes down
and it's like you know it's okay we got
this and pretty much like all you know
like that they need to make like wait
around a fourth field or some of like
all these tough women all the Marvel
women come together and they're gonna go
no there'd the way they were all just
great very ten a lady gonna do
like they just want get them all
together or like uh was it Black
Panthers sister she has a little zappy
hand but like that's about it I'm like
you two are gonna do I think you just
want to be able lineups good yeah that
felt very like if it felt very felt very
rehearse some hell yeah Forrest I guess
is yeah cuz I'm just like what they just
all were like only all the women only
were just right next to each other were
they fighting in gender you know you
know they did that so they can get a
Marvel poster and then something like
marble
you know people can pull it which is
like cool okay you know didn't feel like
you know we're having this moment now
you know kind of thing you know yeah and
the thing is I like I don't know I was
enjoying them fighting on their own like
watching Valkyrie kick-ass and watching
you know yeah you know Captain Marvel
just flying doing her thing like no
honestly you know what we're we were
pissing on Captain Marvel a little bit
but uh she does have a cool yeah like
that was legit awesome she has a line
with Peter Parker too that I think is
the only line that felt natural and
welcome I know what you're thinking like
you got something for me yeah single
moment there I'm like I feel like
there's a personality wait wait that was
no it's on 24/7 that Mel gets those are
the only scenes in the original movie
where she count where to when she was
just like you know hi oh you know I am
okay oh wait wait connection the galaxy
okay sure okay is like that she did well
the very matter all early scenes in this
movie they were just super stiff yeah so
but ya know that one line like that's so
fun you thought that you're a split
second I'm like right there like there's
a person like just bottle that do that
but now it's one of those things where
it's like I don't cuz I so I so like
Thor so when I see him like hey the beer
by haha that's fight but there's like no
no he's like this the whole movie but
then you give him that cool scene where
like he gets the hammer he gets the
electricity and stuff man it's like I
think he has the muscles back I don't
know if he just has a bigger suit I
don't know
but so it's like okay at least he had
that seam but that's like he goes back
to being pudgy and I'm just like it does
feel a little weird like I don't know
cuz it is funny and I guess like I'm
sure he'll get it back sign up but just
knowing ya games like that is very odd
I'll uh I loved the way captain's shield
kept getting smashed because that just
told me like it's supposed to be the
strongest thing that just tells you like
how powerful that oh the Thanos yeah
I loved Chris Evans for whatever reason
when he says adventures he goes simple
it was very Bruce Campbell evil led to
my I loved that scene just gloriously
shot action sequence to that whole third
part ya know and then you know what and
when you say like infinity war what you
imagine the actual war blood of a sandy
war it's like the end of actual infinity
war which is pretty damn good
and then that one just with all the
characters they're all together and
they're all running there's the beams
opening up there's monsters there's a
giant ant-man run it's all of the game
game of like either hot potato or rugby
or like where is like black pants like
give it to me I got this and then like
his spider-man grabs it they keep just
like running with a gobbler like passing
it off to different peoples like a
football game yeah yeah so and you know
with the man that that bit then you were
mentioning now that were in spoiler
territory like yeah I was with you when
they said five years later I'm like we
are really diverging from but yeah five
years I know what you're doing because I
feel like I'm like okay there's some
surprises in this I don't know 100% what
they're doing yeah no I when I saw that
I kind of chuckled like cool we're doing
this and I'm like oh this is to me it's
like what Nolan did with Batman Begins
and Dark Knight where it's like yeah
it's like BAM and you're one in the long
Halloween in spirit but there's giant
like liberties a you it could be like
yes it's like those but we're definitely
doing our own thing and I know it's one
of those things where honestly this
movie does a lot of things that I like I
usually want to see done in a movie like
this and it's like I still do it's
really if somehow they could mix in that
character development while also feeling
like other characters are missing but
like I don't want to say more humor but
like maybe a bit more interesting action
or it says something
creative with the rain with me I'm
traveling yes I said I feel like it felt
so joyful to see them come back because
it was so dour yeah like I fish that was
dog no I mean it's like it's tough cuz I
gotta let it sit rather sit through a
long movie though where the scenes are
good versus just a short movie that's
just crap yeah no I know all the scenes
were good like I've sat through sure way
shorter films that we've had to review
like doing the nostalgia critic and
stuff that felt like an eternity
yeah what and this I mean to me this
felt this definitely felt the length and
there were times where I'm like I'm
getting antsy yeah I'm getting bored I I
don't know I I don't know if there's all
coming together and then when you get to
the third act it's like okay now I see
what you're doing now I see how that
though now I see how that pays off okay
all right this this worked but man that
was a long two and a half hours like we
do any damn way but all three Lord of
the Rings movies and like Titanic and so
like I'm like this is fine I can do this
yeah so it is something where it's like
I I did like it when anyway it was all
done I'm like okay good
yeah if I was to watch this again I
think maybe one more time I would watch
the first two-thirds buy/price just
watch that last third watch the whole
thing again I could watch it like maybe
one more time there is there is a weird
irony though which is even as much as
like you know my friends I drove
infinity more picture that's hanging on
my wall in the office and we read it and
enjoy it as kids as an adult they're not
my favorite movies I mean they're up
there I really like the first one I like
I I liked infinitely more a lot but
they're more like in that like fifth
category and like a top five I like I
still like I like
soldier a lot I like guardians of a
galaxy like it's kind of like it's there
it's not my absolute favorite but
neither was Avengers the first one and I
don't say this of like the tone and
everything of Avengers like compared to
this that day yeah it's night it's night
and day that's making Avengers look the
first we look a little more like
frivolous with every like no but okay
even when it came out we are alike this
movie is so much fun it's yeah great
it's a lot of fun but everybody was
going it at the time the greatest comic
book movie everything I'm like wow well
no no I think again with that I think
they're talking about the idea of these
movies that were building up to of these
characters they add their own films
coming together and doing what they do
in comic book they're actually flying
through the city and they're getting
together in their game don't kill that's
what kills a life to Mars we got all
these people to assemble into one team
now we've got all these teams assembling
into one hour yeah it's one of those
things where it's like as movies went on
it's kinda like okay cool we've done the
cow book things we done that part
cowboys now let's do like the issues and
stuff exactly it's real I gonna top this
and they'll build up a new I guess
fighter man their new Captain America
like that gonna be like series just got
weirder as it went out I'm kind of
hoping they don't like they'll go
another well they already called this
one infinity Wars that I can't call the
yeah but like yeah I but yeah I'm just
trying to think I'm like how do you top
what you did here no no it's comic books
man I need you're just gonna cut go in
the comics they have a lot of great you
know there's so many of them they've got
to be something it's like oh that could
that easily you know if it's just like a
small story it could have something
that's like oh my god that's amazing I
look cool cinematic so I think the last
thing I'll say is that with the the
scene that and everyone you you can hear
all the sniffing from everyone stuff was
the big Tony Stark
death what a surprise um no I know what
is coming in they're still getting this
to know the the the two things that that
really like I like that he does not have
I mean he has like I am Iron Man he does
that like I wanted to say I am done
but I like that after that he doesn't
have a last quip he you know honestly
going to penalize and I love it just you
know we're okay now you can sleep that's
just a nice quiet you know end it's like
that that felt very earned everything
you know about and then the funeral at
the end usually a lot of those funeral
scenes and movies it's like if they make
them really long and drawn-out to make
them feel more important when they're
really not but again this is so many
movies and now only to so many of them
all of it
no no seeing them all there but it's
really earned because this really is
it's not just the Iron Man movie that
started it really is Robert Downey jr.
because we get down to it yes
those movies are either ok or not even
that great but he makes them he 100%
makes them not to save a lot more talent
and stuff behind it by me more than
anybody in the you know lexicon what do
you like his Iron Man films the best is
what made Marvel what it is yeah pretty
much created like this cinematic you
know even though they had other movies
and stuff they it's like the snow yeah
yeah it was like that kind of like he
was the starting point he was the kind
of uniting factor so when you're seeing
everybody react it's one of those things
where you feel like yeah you know a lot
of these characters and everything
wouldn't be here probably if it wasn't
for him doing such a good job as Iron
Man and I kind of me that like the his
death scene was getting me all
misty-eyed
I think the big one for me where I was
like oh my god was the the little flower
wreath that had the heart on it's as
proof that Tony's he has a heart oh no
this is just like that got me yeah I
know that funeral I thought was great I
think you need that let here here's the
thing I almost thought too like okay
with with the funeral and with Captain
America going back in time that you just
see him as an old man I'm thinking to
myself you know if this was in the first
2/3 we would see Captain America's sea
to name and they would talk again and he
would explain everything and they have a
long motional hug and with Tony Stark we
would see people get up and speak at the
funeral and say and this was just so
short and so tight and it just showed
you exactly what you needed this by the
way but it also seems like you was
building up to it as well so it's like
I'm so I'm so - Lauren like don't like
him I love Peter Jackson's Lord the
Rings and I do not despise the the
ending like a lot of people do that goes
on forever but this I feel is the better
example of just like here's how to do a
long ending a long wait
you don't get how do I do that you don't
make it look like yeah that's the thing
Peter Jackson kept making it look like
it was gonna end and this just kept
going and it felt really good an answer
I'm like I wish Lord the Rings have done
it this way yeah you got everyone in one
shot and then you don't get another
goodbye necessary and another goodbye
and another goodbye it's like of the
same characters it's like no you you
legit you got everybody there now some
of those characters gonna show up in our
movies anyway another series but ya know
I thought that was really from when
Thanos blows up that building which is
always so funny kappa movies i mean this
is like a mushroom cloud explosion it's
like well how are they gonna get this
one of course they are yeah roll in my
eye i was rolling my eyes too bad just
because i thought oh wow
like maybe they're gonna have to go back
in time again I thought Tony
like took a missile to his chest
I like when when that thing blew up I
swear to god you just saw three missiles
just go right through the window and
explode next to Tony I thought that's
where Tony was gonna buy it like right
there and instead he like gets of what
girl fine yeah no I thought I was gonna
be a - it's just like oh like his
head yeah I'm like it can't go down that
way so yeah I I did enjoy it um I loved
it : I know it's like the end of an era
and I feel like I feel it was worth it
was earned yeah it was then 21 movies if
they want to tell it in three hours
and they want to make it feel long in
the first part so you're happy when they
show up again then I say let them do it
no it's like I said I think I got lets
it because everything you said is
totally valid that it does feel like
something's missing it does feel kind of
long and drawn-out because those people
are not there to interact so you feel
the lowliness and it's all everything
that everybody's doing is building up to
this could be their last movie this
could be it
you know this could be how they spend
how this character spends the rest of
their days so it kind of makes sense
that all of them would have X amount of
time and they would do the things that
they do with them so it's just it's just
so yeah that's about it yeah that's
about it and we'll just see it the next
the holy movie that comes out I
don't know there's any one's bigger than
this that's gonna except for Lion King
of course and Aladdin what's gonna
happen in those what original ideas
that's all been building up to this like
I'm just feelings
sorry it looks like a fake movie it does
it looks like a bacon I like Will Smith
do it again soon I'm just like I feel
bad for a being and it just God ya know
just terrible no more Disney remake
please please stop please stop but don't
let that be the next phase it's Disney
remakes Oh Captain Marvel with Simba so
I don't know they they do it you know
they do it so yeah you look like you're
thinking of a joke they're like we've
gone on long enough so tired ya know
it's a walk back yeah we got Bagley yeah
so cool cool I will see you guys next
time take care patient
you